after a pride-filled day in los angeles
on saturday complete with naked gay men
and bondage gear parading through the
streets and acting out their sexual
fetishes in front of children while
morbidly obese drag queens stood on
parade floats and shouted about lube
into megaphones festivities culminated
in a grand finale uh musical performance
the la pride in the park music festival
billed itself as an all-ages
kid-friendly event
which in fact the entire all the pride
parades and all the pride events
claim to be all ages and kid-friendly
but we know what these people mean when
they say kid friendly essentially a
kid-friendly activity is any activity
they feel like engaging in with kids
present
they don't judge whether something is
kid-friendly before doing it in front of
kids they do it in front of kids and
then declare after the fact that it was
kid friendly because they did it in
front of kids
and so it perhaps should not be a
surprise that former pop star christina
aguilera took to the stage during this
concert to perform a song called xxx
alongside a transgender singer named kim
petras and for the performance aguilera
wore a green hulk suit and a strap-on
dildo
she then simulated masturbation as she
danced across the stage while drunkenly
shouting the lyrics to what just may be
the dumbest song ever written and
there's a lot of competition for that
title but listen
[Music]
[Applause]
666
[Music]
yes the song largely consists of the
word sex repeated over and over again uh
there are also graphic descriptions of
various sex acts
in the song but in case you aren't
picking up on the theme they continue to
shout the word sex in the refrain like
do you get it this song's about sex you
know sex aren't you impressed aren't we
edgy isn't this an edgy song guys did
you hear us we said the word sex
what they lack in wit or subtlety
they'll make up for by beating you over
the head with a sledgehammer until
you've lost enough brain cells to
actually enjoy a song like this maybe by
the time your your mental capacity
matches that of like a dishrag or joe
biden you might find yourself tapping
your foot and nodding along to the song
it is interesting though to consider
that janet jackson was around the age
christina aguilera is now when she
performed at the super bowl in the early
2000s
and back then it was a major scandal a
huge national story when an aging pop
star showed her nipple for a few seconds
now an aging pop star can gyrate across
the stage in front of kids while
screaming about sex and waving her dildo
around and it's barely noticed by
anybody apart from a few approving
write-ups by the entertainment rags now
that's understandable in a certain way
it's difficult to keep up with all of
the shameless perversion and depravity
especially during pride month after all
this happened just a day after postmates
which is a food delivery service owned
by uber
ran an ad introducing their new quote
bottom friendly menu
now i can't even play most of this ad
and if i could play it i still wouldn't
play most of it but here's just enough
to uh get the gist of it and the main
reason i want to play this for you is
that if you haven't seen it and i
describe it you will think i'm making it
up but i am not
watch
what are you eating this pride
well if you're a top it seems like you
can eat whatever you want
but if you're a bottom you're expected
to starve
not this pride introducing the bottom
friendly menu from postmates
we teamed up with dr evan goldstein from
bespoke surgical to bring you a menu of
bottom friendly foods backed by science
insoluble fiber won't help you feel cute
so avoid things like whole grains sweet
bran cauliflower potatoes legumes hold
up are you just fully diving into those
beans
like i said subtle subtle as always um
now to be totally clear about what you
just heard this is a major food delivery
service which now has a section on its
website for food items you should eat
before engaging in sodomy they have a
sodomy section on their menu
essentially they imagined what would
what it would have been like if sodom
and gomorrah had doordash
and then they went and just made that
dream a reality
meanwhile lost in the shuffle between
the sodomy menu and christina aguilera
in a dildo was the latest episode of
rupaul's dragway drag race in which
nancy pelosi
wandered onto stage to deliver a canned
stump speech about the wonders of drag
because these days politicians actually
have canned stump speeches about the
wonders of drag
watch
please give a warm drag race welcome to
the speaker of the house nancy pelosi
[Music]
welcome back
my honor to be here
to say to all of you how proud we all
are of you
thank you for the joy and beauty you
bring to the world oh your freedom of
expression of yourselves in drag is what
america is all about
everybody on that stage by the way is
completely wasted including and
especially nancy pelosi now
drag is what america is all about says
the speaker of the house
the men who stormed the beaches of
normandy
thought they were fighting for freedom
family righteousness truth
turns out they were mostly fighting for
drag
many brave souls have died to protect
the sacred right of men to cross-dress
as characters from nightmare before
christmas because that's always the
preferred drag aesthetic for some reason
so so uh so what's going on here what
are we witnessing
i think there are two things that are
related
one is that our culture has been
coarsened to the point of non-existence
now cultures are supposed to be living
breathing vibrant things cultures are
rich with tradition and history
a culture preserves the heritage of your
ancestors and leaves a legacy for future
descendants
a culture is the summation of the art
and history and traditions and
accomplishments of a people a people's
culture is supposed to tell you what
those people value what they care about
who they are
that is not our culture
because we don't have one ours is an
anti-culture
our culture is the absence of culture
our culture is a giant
black hole
from which no light can escape
the left isn't concerned with building
anything making anything preserving
anything creating anything instead they
destroy that's all they do
even the music doesn't exist for its own
sake our pop stars they don't make music
they make anti-music
the music is a testament to what it
isn't
that's the only point of the music is
what it isn't
we have pop stars shouting the word sex
while running around the stage with
dildos not because this is the kind of
music they want to make but because it's
the opposite of the kind of music they
don't want to make or anyone to make
namely beautiful and meaningful music
music that points to truth
to the eternal
to the transcendent as all art is
supposed to do
not anti-art though
this is the case with everything in our
anti-culture
everything is broken down and replaced
with nothing
words are emptied of meaning but not
infused with any new meaning
everything is nothing
and nothing is meant to mean anything
the other point is that we're now
witnessing the institutionalization of
debauchery
institutionalized
debauchery
when uber is making ads promoting anal
sex and former mickey mouse club pop
stars are running around with dildos and
the speaker of the house is appearing on
stage with drag queens it means that
debauchery and perversion and depravity
have been totally institutionalized
you cannot rebel against the system by
acting like an insane stupid sex-crazed
fiend
because that is the system that's what
the system is all about
the bad news about this is that it means
that our institutions are completely
gone we have lost them they are just
gone
but the good news
is that the more that this stuff is
promoted by high-ranking politicians and
faceless corporations the less
rebellious and interesting and unique it
seems that's why the perverts are
growing increasingly desperate to shock
and offend us and the harder they try
the more difficult it is for them
all of their antics are bored and tired
and cliched
now there may have been a time when drag
queens represented a rebellion of sorts
but not anymore
not when nancy pelosi is standing there
with them
these days if you want to rebel against
the system you have to do it by
rejecting all of those things
the most rebellious thing you can do is
lead a good decent normal life
rooted in moral truth and sanity
that's the most rebellious thing you
want to be a rebel that's what you do
that's the advantage we have now in the
culture i think anyone who wants to
rebel against the system anyone who
wants to stick their middle finger up to
the man or the them or however the man
identifies these days has to do it by
rejecting the degeneracy and moral
corruption
that the system peddles
that again is the good news
that we are the counter culture now
we are the rebels
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated
you